sérieusement on arrête de rigoler bon
alors voilà ce que je vous demande moi
une immersion totale d'un milieu des
artistes
il ne l'est pas à croire que c'est une
petite balade de santé un mécano d'alger
gt1
je me présente
arthur blanche fait quoi dans la vie
arthur je suis comédien
sinon vous là vous emmener tous âges et
déjà commencé à à repérer certains
membres de la borne
mais une fois encore un petit peu de
temps pour gagner totalement la leur
confiance si je me précipite je me faire
opérer mais le mans j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] je veux le meneur de la bande
titoune attend plus avoir ton qui se
greffe le lasso je suis ni quand
crinière de la matrice et on abolit
mouly sort à des lions move pour les
urnes les manifestants
salut les gars t'es quoi c'est ce même
service tourneur on verra avec la
figuration a commencé à éliminer un par
un on va faire ça aux siennes en salle
ou la case in heels américains disent
juste oui moi j'ai plus loin tu dis
faites le